avec volets une phrase bonjour hélène
revanche revue de presse consacrée à
cette tuerie donc est en deuil à nouveau
les états unis elle a eu lieu cette nuit
dans une école de la petite fille la
petite ville d'où valdi au texas on
rappelle ce bilan effroyable dix neuf
enfants et deux enseignants ou qu'ils
ont été tués horrible incompréhensible a
réagi le gouverneur du texas oui
horrible le mot est approprié pour ces
mères et ses pairs qui ont déposé leurs
petits à l'école mardi matin horrible a
été le moment où ils ont appris la
nouvelle horrible seront leurs nuits de
larmes sans fin horrible seront les
matins lumineux et ensoleillé quand ils
se souviendront que ce n'était pas un
rêve qu'ils verront que le lit est vide
sans la petite bosse sous les
couvertures attendant d'être réveillé
mais incompréhensible le deuxième mot
employé par le républicain john chabot
relève autant de la lâcheté que du
mensonge éhonté singles et houston
chronicle personne et surtout pas le
gouverneur d'un état dont les lois sur
les armes à feu sont les plus ineptes
les plus irresponsables et les plus
dangereuses de ce pays nous devrait se
sentir confus ou incapables de
comprendre les raisons de cette tragédie
sans fin des fusillades de masse aux
états unis la presse conservatrice
helena a une autre explication pour le
fort worth star telegram le problème
relève rémois des armes à feu que d'une
épidémie de maladie mentale qui
pousserait des enfants à tuer d'autres
enfants le tueur présumé on l'a évoqué
tués dans la fusillade et est âgé de 18
ans tout juste le quotidien local évoque
une jeunesse en colère déconnecté voire
désespérée touchés par un problème que
la pop en 2000 aurait tout simplement
amplifié l'isolément la perte de lien
social la dépendance aux écrans étant
présenté comme un mélange toxique
s'ajoute en difficulté inhérente je cite
à l'aide de l'essence dans la presse
américaine il ya aussi ces statistiques
accablantes 27 fusillade dans des écoles
américaines depuis le d de cette année
selon la radio publique npr qui fait
état de 34 incidents de cet ordre en
2021 la dernière l'école la fusillade de
l'école du val di fréquentait à 90% par
des enfants d'origine hispanique
intervient dix jours seulement après une
autre tuerie à buffalo où 10 à pois
américain cette fois avaient été tués
dans un supermarché de new york times
cet état d'au moins 215 fusillade à
travers tout le pays depuis le début là
encore de cette année 2022 sont les
chiffres président est représentée par
les autorités les meurtres ont augmenté
de 40% aux etats-unis depuis le début de
la pandémie globale dan on l'a entendue
dans le journal a réagi en déclarant
qu'il était je cite temps d'agir contre
le lobby des armes
cet appel à l'action du président laisse
sceptique le washington post qu'il
accuse d'avoir joué un rôle central dans
les efforts infructueux pour promulguer
une législation significative sur les
armes à feu malgré dix ans de fusillades
de masse de 110 groupe en 2012 ayew
vallier en passant par buffalo le
journal rappelle notamment que joe biden
avait été chargé par barack obama au
lendemain de son duke de mener en tant
que vice-président la bataille auprès du
congrès pour modifier la législation sur
les armes à feu une bataille que joe
boyd n'a pas su ou pas pu remporter
jusqu'à présent l'échec de ce combat la
répétition des tueries de masse ou 10e à
l'instant nourrissent hélène la colère
des pourfendeurs des armes à feu l
amérique a du sang sur les mains et
atlantique se dit ulcérée par ces
pensées et prières adressées adnot et
âme aux victimes de tueries à leurs
proches au départ ces mots étaient un
cliché puis ils sont devenus une
plaisanterie avant de se purifier en
compte national s'indigne la revue
américaine los angeles times qui parle
de suicide national site abraham lincoln
l'un des pères fondateurs américains qui
prédisaient que les états unis ne
seraient jamais renversé par un ennemi
étranger que le principal danger pour la
nation américaine s'était elle même est
ce là que meurt le rêve américain non
pas sur un champ de bataille mais dans
notre propre maison
et dans nos écoles de nos propres mains
et demain de nos voisins une indignation
enfin eden partagé par les dessinateurs
de presse qui disent parfois mieux que
d'autres les choses walton elle semaine
dont le dessin publié pas des nues
orleans advocate voit le débat sur les
armes à feu tourner en rond son pays
enfermés dans un cercle vicieux un fou
provoque une tuerie de masse qui
pourrait à son tour la colère de
l'opinion les pensées et les prières des
lois laxistes sur les armes à feu des
discours de haine et ainsi de suite les
impasses et les contradictions
américaine dénoncé par michael ii hader
pour halifax chronicle herald
le dessinateur qui fait allusion à la
possible décision de la cour suprême qu
on a beaucoup évoqué ici d'entraver le
droit à l'avortement s'interroge sur la
défense du droit à posséder une arme par
ceux là même qui militent en faveur de
cette interdiction les pro vie comme si
ceux comme ils se sont baptisés eux
mêmes les armureries prolifèrent mais
les cabinets pratiquant les ivg sont
réduits à la clandestinité
dans le dessin des dames lagos pour de
boeuf à la news l'oncle sam partage son
héritage avec la jeune génération une
épidémie d'armes à feu la terreur le
racisme un jour tout cela sera à toi mon
fils dix neuf enfants tués donc et deux
enseignants au texas est oui merci
hélène c'était la revue de presse on en
reparle dès le début du journal de 9h30
avec matthieu mabin qui nous attend à
washington a tout de suite
[Musique]